first up we're gonna bring up another guy actually
from tennessee they keep coming here i don't
know why tennessee must be really bad we're not
worried about that get it from matt boyd everybody
and his opponent one of the newest regulars
on Kill Tony. give it up for hans kim
all right rock paper scissors
let's get this going hard
all right thank god that was
faster for hans and matt everybody
guys as adam said hans is a regular on the kill
tony podcast which means that he gets to do one
minute of stand up every week and they also
pay strippers to come to the club and kiss him
i didn't know that make-a-wish
was sponsoring autistic adults
thank you trailer park gollum
you're welcome hacky chan
very rarely have i been a goal body for someone.
I look like if Matt Boyd was on steroids.
how does it feel to know that you'll
never be as masculine as an asian man
thank you mommy lee we appreciate it
hans has sex like he does comedy
very boring one minute at a time
and whenever tony hitchcliff tells him he can
which is more than you ever have said
thank you disney channels boulogne
you want to find out yes people going for the
assistant coach for our high
school girls volleyball team
matt is as respected in the comedy
community as he is in the pickup basketball
they community laughter is the best medicine
but you should still take your testosterone
hans looks like he jerks off the mythbusters
thank you resting snitch face
matt boyd is not a pedophile
because if you're a child and you can't
overpower a mat boyd that's on you
hans hasn't told his parents
yet that he's a tony's lap dog
he's not embarrassed he's just
afraid they'll try to eat them
he's the only reason you think you're funny
he's the same size as you are he's as
funny as you are so no one knows you
your whole youtube channel is about to
keep it going um give it up for
the tiniest confederate monument
the only way to take down this
statue is with a lawn mower
hans has a lot in common with the
homeless people here in austin
he lives in a van he annoys people on sixth street
and he lost a lot of people in the korean war
that point is what happens to you when your
mom smokes drinks snorts shoots
up and goes on roller coasters
for these guys let's see
who thinks matt boyd makes
that's pretty close i'm
thinking maybe one more joke
all right
matt boyd has a perfect body
for begging on sixth street
you just do my last joke he's what men would
look like if hillary clinton got elected
hans looks like if ryan gosling
stared at the sun for too long
ah
oh
good job boys